you've talked a lot about Central Bank
digital currencies for those of you that
are maybe newer to the concept or my
channel like the government is going to
tokenize
um dollars on the blockchain and it's
programmable money they can program its
value the duration of its value where
you can and can't spend it they can
track where you do spend it or don't
spend it they could
um if they want to implement climate
lockdowns for example and you're
consuming too much meat or buying things
that might contribute to what they might
believe uh harms the environment they
might restrict your access to buying
those those certain things so cbdc's are
are are very interesting can you talk a
little bit more about cbdc's when do you
think they're going to be mainstream
like when will we lose paper money and
have to switch over to some sort of
digital wallet that that that forces us
to transact in their blockchain
so this is a very very uh
uh extensive topic I mean this this is
like a two-hour topic but if I were to
summarize
I would say
as far as the mechanics I think it's
very important for people to understand
the mechanics of a cbdc because when you
hear this in the mainstream Media or on
financial Twitter on YouTube a lot of
YouTube gurus you know talk about this
and they talk about how we're going to
come out this fed coin as though it's
going to be a different career you know
we already talked about cbdc's that
sounds different than a dollar so
somehow we're going to get these uh you
know dollars that we used to use and now
they're going to be replaced by let's
say fed coin
you've got to eliminate that thinking
because that takes you down a path that
leads you to very inaccurate conclusions
okay what you have to understand is that
money itself the way we think of money
outside of green pieces of paper is
nothing but a ledger
that's it so rich I I'm sure you have a
few bank accounts
what that bank account that is not money
there's no money being stored for you in
there safe that is just that that whole
Bank all they're doing is keeping track
of a ledger
of who owes who what and all these
arguably you know you could say that it
exists today
sorry arguably you could say that
Central Bank digital currencies exist
today well there you go so the thought
experiment that I like to do is I ask
people how do you know that you're not
spending a cbdc right now like do you
think they're gonna come out and tell
you
absolutely not so the point is a cbdc by
definition is when all of these ledgers
are Consolidated onto one
if they're on just one Ledger then they
can do all of these things all these
Draconian are orwellian Big Brother type
of things that you described just a
couple minutes ago they can't do that
unless you've got everything on one
Ledger or the ledgers are at least
talking with one another so you've got
the bis coming out the other day talking
about this unified a global unified
Ledger in terms of a cbdc is what I've
been talking about on my channel for the
last two years now right and what
they're doing is you'll notice in this
report they don't talk necessarily about
a different type of money or different
type of currency it's all about unifying
ledgers so and the reason I say this is
because there's so many people that I
see out there that are adamantly opposed
to a cbdc but they'll sit there and if
the FED says okay well now instead of
your deposits being a liability of Wells
Fargo you know we don't don't have to
worry about them going bust you can just
move them onto the fed's balance sheet
those same people would say oh yeah sure
that doesn't sound like a big problem
that you know they pay me a higher
interest rate why not but they don't
understand that that is a cbdc and they
don't understand that the central
planners aren't going to come out and
tell you they're not going to say you
know today we're using this new cbdc why
would they do that when they know that
there's so much negative press there's
so much negative PR on social media
around the topic people know that it's
big brother so what they're going to do
how they're going to roll this out rich
in my opinion because this is exactly
what I would do you know if you just put
on the Evil Genius hat for a moment if
you go on your Klaus Schwab hat uh you
come to the conclusion that you only
start rolling out the features of a CBC
so the feature one of the features of
everything Beyond one Ledger is you'll
be able to settle transactions 24 7 365
instantly all over the world
so I know you're a Canadian you probably
have most of your currency units in
Canadian dollars so let's say that you
take a trip down to Mexico you know we
talked about that trip here uh are you
talking about that trip you do annually
so you go down to Mexico and let's just
say that you're down there and you
wanted to buy a property like oh man I
love it down here great you know beach
front and but it's going to be a pain in
the ass because you're going to have to
wire that money from your account and
Canada's gonna have to come down to
Mexico you're going to set up account
you're going to trade it from Canadian
Dollars into Pesos it's going to take
all this paperwork all this time you
have to pay transaction fees then you've
got to get it in the account of the
seller how do you do escrow how do you
it's big pain in the ass right well with
a unified Ledger the cbdc world if you
will
if you were down there you would
instantly be able to transfer those
currency units from Canada down to pesos
you'd instantly be able to transfer them
from Canadian dollars to Mexican pesos
and you'd be able to direct them right
into the account of the seller all free
24 7 365. so this is one of the reasons
why I don't think a cbdc will be thrust
upon people I think they'll actually
demand it I think that they'll they'll
love it because the the average Joe just
doesn't understand what's happening here
right so if I'm Klaus Schwab I'm going
to roll out those features just
gradually I'm not going to say that it's
a cbdc I'm going to say look now look
what you can do with this new banking
system we'll call it fed now we've we've
set it up and oh it's so amazing you can
do this and you can do that if we're
going to say yeah yeah yeah very very
cool and then three four five years down
the line once they get everyone uh on
this network and once they integrate it
into their life then they're going to
start rolling out the social score
another uh thought experiment that I use
with my audience and is all of us
everyone on the live stream right now
has a cell phone and I would argue 99 of
the people are probably addicted to it
even on this live stream right now no
matter what you say
so if I told you that tomorrow the
government the Canadian government or
the U.S government would start giving
you a social score or a climate score
based on your cell phone usage how many
of you would continue to use your cell
phone
every single person why because it's
completely integrated into their life
they can't even leave home for five
minutes without their cell phone they're
just and maybe your audience is a little
bit different rich but I mean for
heaven's sakes go through an airport in
Canada or in the United States I mean 99
of the people what are they doing
they're literally running into each
other because they've just got their
head buried and their stupid phone for
heaven's sakes so you're not and what
they're going to do is they're just
going to rationalize it oh yo oh man I
don't want that social score no I know
that's bad but I Know Rich is
overplaying it on his channel and George
he's just a fear monger and he's just
doing click bait and he's just trying to
he's got the tinfoil hat ons I don't
know it means it really that bad they're
gonna sit there and rationalize it right
just like people rationalize uh the the
blue pill guys sit there and rationalize
why they should do this for a girl or
why they should get her roses or why
they should do that or why they
shouldn't go to the gym you know they
know they should but then they
rationalize it away to where they don't
have to do it and I think people are
going to do the exact same thing with a
cbdc so that's what I would say first
and foremost understand that it's a
ledger understand that you're not going
to know when they roll it out unless
you're really really really paying
attention and then once you start paying
attention then you know that you want to
try to transact
in cash as much as you can and
unfortunately Bitcoin and gold it's it's
very tough to transact you know try
going a week in your life and only
spending Bitcoin uh that that's that's
that's going to be difficult you know to
pay your rent to pay your uh Insurance
Etc but the the way that you've got to
start thinking about is how could I
operate or how can I live outside of
that ledger as much as possible now the
people are that have nine to fives and
jobs and even for you and I rich we're
gonna have to have some of our uh net
worth on that ledger because we've got
to transact unless we want our uh
quality of life or standard of living to
go down to like an Amish community right
if you don't want that then some portion
is going to have to operate within that
ledger but you want to try to get as
much
out of that ledger as you can and that's
where Bitcoin comes in that's where gold
comes in and you take those uh you know
what you don't need as a store of value
then you take that turn it into currency
cash and that's what you use to transact
with as much as possible so this really
puts a premium for people who've really
value privacy and freedom and liberty
and all these things it really puts a
premium on finding and setting up a plan
b or c in countries where the majority
of transactions are still settled in
cash you know I did a video on this the
other day Rich do you know that 78 of
the transactions in places like Romania
in Morocco are still settled in cash
so I'm not saying they'll never have a
cbdc there but what I am saying is that
you got a lot more Runway
and uh for me that that's that's very
important so I think you know I could go
talk about it for two hours but I guess
I'll stop there
they rolled out a central bank digital
currency in some cities in China did you
did you hear about how they did that oh
sure they just give people free money I
mean that's another way you know there's
basically I said here's here's fifty
dollars worth of whatever our you know
free free currency is and apparently
nobody pushed back on it they were all
happy to get that free money and and
start using it to move them in that
direction yeah I mean look if
so the other day I went on Twitter
and I said that
you have to acknowledge the features
of a cbdc
or a unified Ledger in the eyes of Joe
public and I said I think that the free
market may even
gravitate towards a cbdc and of course I
have all the bitcoiners and gold people
I mean they're just literally losing
their mind right their heads are
exploding and I said no you've got and
of course they don't understand what I'm
saying what I'm really saying
is
if you're fighting Jon Jones
maybe the best UFC fighter at all times
let's say that you're going into the
octagon with him in six weeks
are you gonna Focus strictly on his
weaknesses
of course not you're gonna look at his
weaknesses but you're also going to look
at his strengths
because how the hell are you going to
defeat him
if you don't look at everything and it's
in its uh entirety and then you know how
and what strategy you can use to
actually having a chance of beating this
guy so we have to look at you know how
this cbdc thing rolls out and why the
public will gravitate to it we talked
about the ease of use but then you bring
up a great point they're of course going
to roll out uh Universal basic income
especially when we have the next
recession if it turns into an economic
depression you know we're going to see
the same stemi nonsense that we saw in
and in 2021 and the easiest way to send
out stemis is to do what to have
everyone have an account at the Federal
Reserve instead of their local bank and
then the FED can take those Bank
Reserves call Base money and they can
inject that straight into the economy to
try to give it an economic boost you
notice that Keynesian type of mentality
also you know I saw in fact do you know
what the mises Institute is no The mises
Institute is one of of the big
libertarian uh think tanks in the United
States I mean they're they're in fact
they're amazing they're really really
good but I saw someone with the mises
Institute retweet uh this this
um article where they were arguing how
wrong it is that Jamie dimon he's in
charge of JP Morgan uh how he in in
other words JP Morgan their Reserve
serves or their cash balance their
checking account that they have with the
FED they get paid like five percent on
that it's actually a little bit more but
let's just say five percent where if you
actually bank with JP Morgan they're
only paying you like 50 basis points
right so the article was like why is how
is this Fair on what planet is this
right no no no no we should all be paid
the exact same amount as JP Morgan or
Jamie dimon why should he get more on
his cash reserves than we do the average
Joe and Jane but so the solution there
is what well you just move your account
from JPMorgan over to the fed and the
FED will pay you the exact same interest
rate but what does that do now all of a
sudden you've got the cbdc so they
whoops sorry about that they can pay you
whatever interest rate they want they
can issue Universal basic income you
have all these efficiencies of the
transactions they can also issue uh uh
credit based on narrative not based on
Merit because see if there's only one
balance sheet the can the bank can't go
bust right so the Federal Reserve they
cannot go bust so if the lending is
going through the Federal Reserve and
those assets those loans end up on their
balance sheet they don't care about them
getting paid back where a normal bank
they have to take into consideration
your credit score
obviously because they have a p l and
they they want to get paid back on that
loan but the FED doesn't fall into that
category they cannot go bust so if you
and the way I always describe it is in
the future when we go into the cbdc
world Dylan Mulvaney
will get a loan with zero percent
interest I assure you regardless of what
his credit score is where rich Cooper
it'll be almost impossible for him to
get a loan for anything under a 10
interest rate
you see where I'm going with that
because there although you from a merit
standpoint a bank would far prefer to
loan to you but that's not the way the
fed's thinking see they're thinking in
terms of of politics and whoever
whatever disadvantaged group let's say
has political favor they're the ones
that are going to be getting the loans
it's not going to be the the straight
white guys I can assure you of that
especially this
cars that get five miles to the gallon
yeah so they're definitely going to be
weaponizing that agenda so you're so to
your point of of being able to opt out
of it somehow with something like
Bitcoin is definitely useful I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full-length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out
foreign
all right hey guys welcome uh playing to
win episode number 88. uh my friend
George Gammon returns how you doing
George doing well Rich thanks for having
me back on yeah it's cool to catch up
every uh you know I said last time I'd
love to have you on like every six or
seven months just to sort of you know
see what's going on with the markets
because you know they're always changing
and um you know it's always it's always
neat to sort of dive down those
conversations and we always I mean we we
talk about more than just markets and
economics anyway because I know that
you're you know you're pretty red pill
with the way that you live your life and
everything so
fun to have you on
um
before we actually get started I